let's do this keep everyone alive
holy geez
the nine-ring broadsword
the nine-ring broadsword is a variant on
the chinese dao from the king dynasty
that was used through the 1930s
featuring a blade wider than a
traditional dow and a curve towards the
tip the weapon was ideal for chopping
and could sever a head with a single
swing
the rings on the back of the blade serve
dual purposes for ornamentation used
during ceremonies or martial arts
displays and for superstitious reasons
as it was believed the jingling sound
would ward off evil spirits this deadly
and sacred sword can be seen on the
television show into the badlands
plainsmiths
you have our gratitude
[Music]
gentlemen your swords look magnificent
but are they deadly
to find that out we will take your sword
to deliver some killing blows on this
big
carcass it's all about the kill in this
particular test britain you are first
are you ready sir yes sir
let's do this
see
three
well there it went
[Music]
goodness
all right burton first stop what i love
about this blade was the balance the way
i was able to move with the blade
everywhere
now let's talk about the breakage
okay so the break happened right there
where the ring was attached
you can see it's really not a bad poor
structure you have there it could be
finer but rings when you're digging into
that could cause stress risers and it
broke right there where the ring was
well gentlemen the fight's not over
because mike your blade still has to
survive nine strikes on its kill test
target good luck gentlemen
doug
if i make it through nine strikes on
this pig i'm forging fire champion my
palms are sweating i'm so scared that
this thing's gonna break on the first
swing
[Applause]
so
[Music]
good job bro
burton unfortunately your blade broke
and can no longer continue with testing
and for that reason i have to dismiss
you from the forge
good job brother my brother
sucks dude man gorgeous weapon no thank
you
seeing my blade break uh it's a
disappointment you know when you make it
to round three you want to win
you know the nine holes burnt through
four drill bits doing them so somewhere
through there i probably was given a
little too much pressure and caused the
stress riser to run down that blade that
was enough to cause a critical failure
in that blade i'm still proud of myself
with what i've done you know it was way
out of my wheelhouse
what's next for me is not swords
especially any nine ring swords that's
for damn sure
mike congratulations the strength and
integrity of your blade has made you a
forged and fire champion and that's a
title that comes with a check for ten
thousand dollars good job brother
i have unfortunate fire holy crap man
come on forward and shake our hands
thank you thank you
good job bro thank you because some of
the things that went wrong in my home
forge i was really sure that that blade
was going to break on me
it was a happy dance
the touareg tacoba
[Music]
the tacova is a type of broadsword that
has been used by the nomadic taureg
people of north africa since the 14th
century
this double-edged lightweight blade was
carried for self-defense on long
journeys designed to deliver lethal
slashes and stabs against a rival
warrior
due to the torg's aversion to iron there
is no exposed steel or iron on the hilt
of this sword so it cannot touch the
user's hand
measuring more than a meter long this
deadly weapon was seen as a symbol of
wealth some members of the tacoba clan
still carry this weapon today
bladesmiths welcome to the keel test
your terrechticobus look beautiful but
the kind of beauty i'm looking for is
the lethal kind i'm going to take your
weapon deliver some lethal blows in this
ballistic stubby dusting up first ready
yes sir let's do this
[Applause]
all right dustin let's talk about
your weapon here
first up your handle construction
i like the avoid feel of this the flare
you have there in your pommel actually
gives great retention for this
your tip
is sharp enough to penetrate your edges
are sharp when you're cutting out and
you can wheel this
to do that kind of damage on this but
it's dummy
overall sir a weapon like this
it will kill
awesome
all right joshua your turn you ready
keep everyone alive all right let's do
this
okay
all right joshua let's talk about your
weapon here your pommel right here could
have used some weight to it but because
it's forward-weighted and the fact that
you have a very sharp edge every slice
that you can see is very deep into the
ballistics dummy and more importantly
sir your weapon
you will kill girl
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test our desert well chop
now to test the strength and overall
construction of your blades i will be
chopping into our well house as well as
the well dustin you're on deck you ready
i guess so
okay
oh
[Music]
all right
we were doing so well for a moment there
what actually happened was
with insetting your blade
down into this piece of wood
any of that leverage was just too much
for the wood itself and it popped it
loose
your tang is a little bit small but what
i do like to see is that your blade
actually held up beautifully i mean your
grain structure looks fine
this is an absolutely brutal test it's
very well done thank you
now dustin you survived every one of the
strikes except for the last one your
guard gave way and your blade followed
so we consider this a catastrophic
failure you cannot continue testing your
blade but you're not out of the fight
yet how you feeling joshua pressure's on
all right so you need to survive five
strikes in order to be named forged and
fire champion you ready yes sir all
right let's do it
well joshua your blade is strong it made
it past all the strikes congratulations
now dustin unfortunately for you that
means your time here in this competition
has ended because you did have a
catastrophic failure it was an honor
watching you in our forge but
unfortunately man at this time i'm gonna
have to ask you to please step off our
forge floor
thank you guys thank you so much i'm
definitely crushed i actually thought
that recessing the sword into the tang a
little bit would make it stronger and
that's kind of what bit me in the end so
definitely definitely won't be doing
that again
i'm definitely proud of this blade
i came here to challenge myself as much
as i could and i definitely achieved
that
well joshua congratulations man that
means you are the newest fortune fire
champion you just got yourself a check
for ten thousand dollars congratulations
[Applause]
yeah
oh my gosh i made a sword it didn't
break oh my gosh it was a hard
competition so this is unreal
the polish carabella
one of europe's most iconic savers the
carabella was a sidearm of history's
most fearsome calvary the winged hussars
these 17th century warriors famed for
their feathered armor and sophisticated
attack formations brandished the sword
on horseback when closing in on the
enemy the sabre's light curved blade
slashed easily through enemy armor its
hilt often included fixtures that
improved grip and recovery like a thumb
ring chain guard or curved eagle head
pommel the carabella was so effective in
helping the hussars defeat enemy armies
much larger in size that it became a
symbol of prestige worn by polish
lithuanian nobility at formal events
its legacy lives on in the video game
series
witcher
bladesmiths this is the kill test to see
what kind of lethal damage your weapon
will do i will take your weapon deliver
some slashes and thrust on this pig
carcass
ethan your first you ready i am so ready
[Music]
all right
how'd it feel
first up there are no issues whatsoever
with your edge over here it is sharp it
lacerates and cuts cleaning look at that
razor cuts right there
on the thrust you have an angle here
that allowed for a deep thrust pulling
out and slashing on the way out overall
your weapon
will kill
all right leon your turn you ready oh
yeah let's do it so many things can go
wrong i don't even know if i was able to
get a good solid temper on this blade
[Music]
well liam let me say this first up
your presence here is a victory all the
things that you went through and you
still turn in a blade that's beautiful
in craftsmanship that is very sharp
but
your blade did break and you can see
right here in the cross section there's
a discoloration down here so something
happened in your heat treating process
it may have micro fractures
it is what it is
liam there was a flaw in your blade that
led to a catastrophic blade failure and
we can no longer continue with testing
for that reason i have to ask you to
please leave the forge
thank you gentlemen
i'm upset
sometimes
the best you can do isn't going to be
enough but that doesn't mean you
shouldn't still try
ethan this is a competition where the
best blade wins and you sir our new
forged and fire champion and that's the
title that comes with a check ten
thousand dollars good job
i really would have liked to have seen
both of those go all the way through
testing but i'm very proud of the work i
did i am now a forage and fire champion
attila the huns
sword of mars
yes
known as the scourge of god attila the
hun was one of the most feared
conquerors in history the leader of the
hanukk empire his group of nomadic
tribes wreaked havoc across europe
during the 5th century though he was
once a great ally to them he played
roman territories sacking major cities
like constantinople legend states that
attila was given the sword of mars by a
herdsman fulfilling a prophecy and a
direct sign from the roman war god mars
of his divine rule
the lethal weapon featured a curved
handle with a spear point tip that gave
it exceptional control allowing for
accurate and brutal thrust after
attila's death in the year 453 the
hunnic empire quickly dissolved however
the story of attila's many conquests
still live on through the television
mini-series attila all right bladesmiths
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do i will deliver
killing blows on this but the sex dummy
randy up first you ready i am let's do
this
nice
all right trying to talk about your
sword of mars here first up the damascus
pattern you have here is gorgeous
the weapon design is very aggressive for
thrusting and slashing now your handle
construction if you reverse this
it'll be easier to have something to
lock onto the fact that the flare is
right here forcing my hand to open up if
i want to marry into the hilt this is a
very sharp weapon the tip pierces
all the way through cuts on the way out
it's pointy and scary and
it will kill right here good job all
right dan it is your turn you ready hell
yeah let's do this i was hoping the kill
test would be a dummy i know heads will
roll
all right dance talk about your weapon
here i love the balance of your blade
when i go forward it's not hard to pull
back to go in again for another kill now
your handle construction it's curved
enough to where it doesn't want to fly
out of my hand it's got a good grip and
control for this your edge allows for
very deep cuts into the abdomen right
there the only issue we have is that
your tip picked up a bend when it's
chopped into the spine
but
your weapon sir will kill thank you
all right gentlemen it's time for the
strength test now attila's armies were
basically one large cavalry and through
his military campaigns he revolutionized
the use of horse in military conflicts
so to test the strength and durability
of your blades i'll be chopping into
these horse skulls
randy you're first you ready i guess so
[Applause]
wow
okay so
right off the bat the biggest thing is
that this section from right about here
to here
has lost its edge
there's a couple of small
rolls
blade's still straight it's all in one
piece still solid nicely done it's a
very strong bite
all right dan are you ready no but let's
do it
everybody says that
[Music]
at the guard
[Music]
okay so
before we get to the obvious i really
like the design of your blade it's got a
great weight to it had a really good
feel in my hand the balance was really
nice
see all that space around your tang
with that room for that blade to move
inside the guard it could just create so
much stress that it cut loose right
there at the corner if it were all tight
there wouldn't be any stress there's no
discoloration here so it's not that
there were it was a crack here before
your grain structure looks fine it was a
well-designed piece but obvious flaw
dan unfortunately your blade suffered a
catastrophic failure in the middle of
our strength test which means that we
can no longer test it
i'd like to invite you to shake our
hands shake your competitor's hand
and then please leave the forge it hurts
but my sword breaking it's gonna be a
reminder that i have to push harder and
be better randy the strength and
efficiency of your weapon in the kill
test have earned you the title of forged
and fire champion and a check for how
much 2000 that's right ten thousand
dollars good job brother i won foraging
fire it's reality how do you feel good
to be a champion and be
recognized as a good blade smith is all
real good
this is my happy and excited face oh yes
sir hey if he didn't recognize it
[Music]
the soda gourami
holy geez
oh my god
one of the most intimidating and
versatile japanese pole weapons the soto
gourami was part of the key arsenal for
samurai police during the 17th century
featuring lethal spikes and hooks police
were able to capture violent offenders
from the distance by using the weapon to
latch onto the suspects stopping them in
their tracks
although primarily used in defense the
sharp spikes along with the spiked bud
cap made it a menacing and brutal weapon
when in combat today the soto gourami's
devastating use can be seen in the hbo
television series westworld all right
bladesmiths welcome to the kill test
to find out what kind of lethal damage
your saudigarami will do i will take
your weapons and stab and try to snag
this ballistics dummy rita you're first
you ready for this hi
all right let's do this
haha
[Music]
all right we let's talk about your
sarigarami the times you have here
penetrates the hook you have here will
rip this person apart and more
importantly your weapon will kill
all right justin your turn you ready to
have fun yes sir
[Music]
all right justin the times you have here
it's more of a stabbing time rather than
a grabbing this is a grabbing weapon but
that hook does grab on to that overall
sir your weapon
will kill
[Music]
all right bladesmiths it's time for the
strength test the dreaded ice block chop
remember this is not about what these
weapons do to the ice blocks but with
those ice blocks due to your weapons and
rita you're up first you get points for
theme i mean
you ready
it doesn't matter right oh it doesn't
matter
okay
[Music]
all right rita got a little bit more of
a bend
in this one tine here
but everything else is pretty much the
way it was going in
definitely held up did his job good job
thank you
all right justin your turn you ready yes
i am
so
[Music]
all right so you survived the strength
test this is a very strong uh well-built
head for this but it's built more like a
spear than it is for catching i mean i'm
not sure how effective it would be at
snagging the opponent but uh it's a
devastator it certainly did the job good
job
all right bladesmiths welcome to the
sharpness test the sandman pierce and
capture
to test the sharpness i will take your
weapon pierce and try to control this
sandman relay you're up first you ready
for this
[Music]
so
all right rita the points you have on
your tines here definitely penetrate
when you thrust into that but it doesn't
slice on the way out or capture as well
as it should
your hook over here did its job overall
it will cut in control
all right justin your turn so you ready
yes i am
[Music]
oh
that's not good
he pulled it out of the socket
well justin we have a problem yes sir
this wasn't pinned was it no
the impact from all these tests loosened
it up and of course it came off
[Music]
justin you brought in a beautifully
crafted weapon however you've suffered a
catastrophic failure in our final test
and unfortunately you cannot be our
fortune fire champion congratulations
rita thank you awesome
coming on force and fire i put my all
into it and i feel like i made a good
weapon but uh just came up short on a
little bit of the fit and finish and
other than that i'm happy with it
[Music]
rita congratulations you are the forged
and fire champion and that is the title
that comes with a check for ten thousand
dollars congratulations
how do you feel right now
come on forward and shake our hands
good job
it's been a very positive and uplifting
experience to be able to do something
amazing like this
i hope this will help me become an
inspiration
to kids because i can say look if you
see something and you want to try it
give it a try
hey weblos your scout leader is the new
fortune fire champion i'm bringing it
home
can i have a group hug please
thank you you guys oh my god
you